a gruesome scene that caught everyone
off guard a darker riddler than we've
ever seen what scene went too far keep
watching spoilers for the batman ahead a
new batman movie has burst forth from
the night and audiences have been loving
the new iteration of the iconic
character robert pattinson perfectly
fits the mold of both bruce wayne and
the caped crusader and of course no
batman is complete without a sinister
villain to fight batman goes up against
the likes of penguin and carmine falcone
in the film but the main baddie that
overshadows them all is riddler batman
is known just as much for his intellect
as his brawn making the riddler a
perfect match for him he leaves behind
riddles at every crime scene and while
they may puzzle everyone else batman is
able to get a good handle on the
situation for the most part this version
of the riddler is unlike anything that's
come before taking on the persona of a
zodiac like serial killer riddler may
have killed before in the comics but
unless you count most of jim carrey's
portrayal he's never done anything quite
this atrocious does anybody else feel
like a pride egg there are many gruesome
scenes in the batman that resemble
moments you might expect out of
something like seven or prisoners but
there's one scene involving riddler that
may be tough to watch even for the
bravest souls in the audience it's
obvious right from the get-go that
riddler doesn't have any sympathy for
his victims in his mind they are the
corrupt elite and they deserve what they
have coming to them he's not even above
sending a video of one of his victims
demises to the local news so that
everyone can see his grand plan in
action during the batman we see a video
made by riddler himself depicting his
capture of commissioner pete savage the
commissioner isn't as clean as everyone
thought and riddler highlights this fact
by strapping an apparatus to his body
this device contains various tubes
linked to a rat cage allowing the
rodents to burrow into him while we
don't see anything too graphic just the
thought of dying that way is a painful
visual to imagine
it's something that a lot of audiences
thought went too far and if you find
yourself having a tingle of familiarity
while watching the scene you aren't
alone the moment bears striking
similarities to a scene in 2008's the
dark knight when the joker sends a tape
to the news depicting his torture of a
batman impersonator that was also a
horrifying scene particularly since it
showed a darker side to joker than what
most people had seen in a film up to
that point
from riddler's tape to the rest of his
time in the batman it will be hard to
look at the character the same way again
villain sending ominous videos to the
local news isn't the only thing the
batman and the dark knight have in
common they both offer more grounded
takes on the character introducing us to
villains who could theoretically exist
in the real world they both depict
batman wanting to go after the mob and
organized crime plaguing gotham and
that's just the tip of the iceberg both
batman movies also make excellent use of
their funeral scenes in the dark knight
there's a massive outdoor funeral
procession for police commissioner loeb
people are naturally on edge from the
joker's attacks and as everyone should
have suspected joker targets the funeral
and makes an attempt on the mayor's life
while he's at the podium similarly the
batman has a funeral scene for the
fallen mayor the festivities are held
inside this time around but that doesn't
stop riddler from sending a runaway car
into the building to scare the daylights
out of everyone inside and of course
there's a special surprise waiting for
everyone inside the vehicle
let's clear this place out now
of course these examples don't suggest
that the two movies are anything alike
they both stand alone as incredible
pieces of superhero cinema raising the
bar for any future projects anything
they have in common is purely surface
level but there's honestly no way to
avoid comparisons between two of the
best batman movies to date both movies
are brutal and as this particular
riddler scene proves they contain some
genuinely terrifying scenes that bring
the batman into darker territory
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one